if you ever heard somebody say that they
have commitment issues they don't
actually have commitment issues they
just don't like the other person that
much it's the same reason people stay in
jobs they hate it's not because they
have commitment issues for the job is
that they're afraid to leave and so
they're more afraid of being alone than
they are and staying in a dead-end
relationship or a dead-end job if you
can confront the fear of the fact that
you're like I just need to have this
hard conversation with this person so
like I'm Just Not That Into You you
don't have a commitment issue you're
just not that into that person and
that's fine and you owe it to them if
you actually care about them as a human
being to let them find someone who is
actually that into them and you owe it
to yourself to give yourself the
opportunity to finally meet someone else
who you don't have commitment issues
with because you would be [__] stoked
to stay with that person for the long
time